Wow
hello I'm Grimes I'm a musician and
artist I'm live I'm a poker player
science youtuber speaker person we're
here today to review deaths trending by
Kojima Productions which we are again
we're very excited about I've heard many
great things about what do you think is
in this box its enormous I think it's
possible that there is a baby in the box
wow this is incredible death stranding
your goal is to reconnect isolated
cities and fragmented society by forming
connections or strands with others to
start your journey
we're gifting you with a customized
boxer inside you'll find a limited
edition death standing ps4 Brad and all
the official cupid necklace as worn by
sandwiches that looks like 4-meter is
that it's kind of the Schrodinger
equation I think it is but it's look
slightly different to normal in in the
game it's it's a world where physics is
slightly off Wow okay sweet what should
we try to set up the game
yeah
[Music]
they're really good at rendering certain
Rockies Oh finally
that's right that's right we thought we
were gonna get a baby I mean what
happened
Oh God
Oh
I can feel it through responses let's
just keep us on the cutting room floor
it's a little inverse gravity Oh No okay
that was did you see that huh
what did did you smell into my stomach
when I was a baby hanging out and then
it puts on that smells I went inside
it's now it's like a lot of bad trips
rolled into one
um but in a in a very gratifying way
despite being required to disclose that
this is an advertisement I need to say
that this is one of the greatest pieces
of art in the 21st century
[Music]